vicki downing street is today described
this as a world-beating plan is it
it's a very interesting idea to force um
builders to rethink the way in which
they put together the houses or when
you're looking at perhaps uh i think
it's included too in what we heard today
um restructuring a building or
renovating or changing the the use of a
particular building that you can
actually now
or you have to be um forced to add
charging points to for electric vehicles
and it does make quite a lot of sense in
my view
but of course we're talking about new
homes uh quite a lot of homes right now
as we know don't have even driveways
where they can park their cars so it
will require quite a lot of rethinking
in terms of where those charging points
really are put and i think just putting
them in the new homes isn't going to be
the answer what people need given that
we now have something like 10 of new
cars being sold being electric you need
proper public charging points you need
to be able to get into a petrol station
of source if you like
and use it just like if you're using it
now for normal fuel and be able to
recharge your batteries quite easily and
quickly which is something that we still
a long long way from being able to get
to have got to really uh it requires
battery production to improve battery
technology to improve and loads more
charging points to be available across a
large part of the uk where it's present
there are big gaps london the southeast
is well provided by comparison quite a
lot of the rest of the uk isn't
yeah and the clock is ticking isn't it
because we know that new petrol and
diesel cars are being phased out by
2030. there's no choice the government's
got to do something donald does this
plan go far and fast enough
it's a tiny step in a direction for
better facilities for evs but of course
what the government's totally ignoring
is actually the need for us to be moving
away from a car culture in our cities 83
of the united kingdom public live in
towns and cities and what we need to be
doing there is investing in cycle lanes
and public transport and we've been
going in the opposite direction on that
public transport has in real terms had
its uh prices increased above inflation
every year for the last 10 years whilst
actually they've reduced the the the
fossil fuel duties for cars and our
investment in um cycle lane
infrastructure is abysmal it's around a
tenth of what the united nations says we
need to be spending
vicki we talked about gas boilers we
talked about home insulation um
in the wider scheme of things
how big a deal is this
ah it's it's not immense i have to say i
think the most important thing of all is
to think about this you know public
charging places that we absolutely need
uh but of course uh the interesting
thing is that when you're looking at how
we might move around in the future of
course i take the point that perhaps we
need to be rethinking whether we use a
car in in cities as much as we do at
present
we've also got a different um
element in terms of how we'll power our
cars hydrogen is being developed now as
the possibility uh of replacing uh
petrol as the main fuel for cars and if
that's the case then quite a lot of
those electric uh charging points may in
fact not be needed so the balance
between the two is going to be really
quite important so what the government i
think is doing which i think is
reasonably clever
is saying that we're not going to be
investing anything ourselves we're
having a law which is going to force
those charging points to appear so
they're not actually spending anything
particularly much on this whereas when
it comes to really investing in hydrogen
technology the government is going to
have to absolutely sit down with
all the the whole the industry and
participate and also share some of the
risk of that so this is a low risk
strategy for them but i think they're
going to need to think a lot more widely
than that